[Music]
all right so everyone has been highly
requesting that we talk about this watch
this do this may be bad especially me
tiger key good morning you cool cats and
kittens today we're talking about Tiger
king cool cats and kit you Carol batten
oh I hate you you Caleb ask questions
take should we free Joe exotic no why
why
if Trump was to pardon Joe exotic I will
sign up for the Trump campaign and then
I'll try to help him with know someone
expert he try to kill Carole bass are
you sure but from I've heard from the
memes she killed her husband ank you we
don't listen to the Bucky mean open the
reinvestigation so but have you heard
the song I'm convinced by music songs
and his music videos pretty sick yeah
dude that music video they found an
exact replica of her she is I Louise
follows her yeah although she's trying
for the same where do they find that the
way that they all talk and stuff and
their logic I wouldn't be surprised if
she really did sign up for the music
video
you mean Carol Baskin herself yeah cuz
you know I actually think that Joe was
set up the whole way through
by Jeff by Jeff watching it that is what
the duck wants you think yeah is this a
kind of show that I have to watch like
right now I need to get home and I need
a watch oh yeah oh yeah is that crazy to
stay up with it no comedy could even
write this [ __ ] yeah it's good
like it's if I watched a comedy series
of scripted comedy and that's how it was
I'd be like they went they did too much
like this is not how real people cuz
it's like trailer trash Game of Thrones
yeah it's so good with all the [ __ ]
drama and the and it's [ __ ] that
crazy and hilarious you don't need an
actor to try to [ __ ] make it funny
like it's already funny just let just
tell the story as it they don't even
have to open their mouth and it's
already funny what they're talking about
wanting to do a a TV show or a movie and
I'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like yeah we'll get David's made I'm
like now that that stuff but also it's
the it's the choices of the
documentarian like the shots they even
like when they bring in the new
characters like remember the the rat the
fat guy with the animal do you remember
the jet ski see of course it's in
Kryptonian Danny McBride did that in
eastbound and that [ __ ] was even funnier
on tiger King because it's just real
people and the guys just like the guys
like I got it [ __ ] made I got it all
figured out it looks like South Park but
really yeah yeah that's so true like how
they all like turn each other in
right and they thought they were in the
clear and they talked to the PETA person
were like now we're still investing here
all these people like that was like one
of the best parts like the way all of
Joe's staff [ __ ] turned on his ass
that was hilarious yeah wait what
episode are you on it's it's focusing on
Carol Baskin right now the heavily so
it's like you're halfway there
you haven't even gotten the best part
where he's [ __ ] runs for governor
yeah have you seen him marrying his
third husband oh I thought when he had
the double marriage okay oh yeah because
we he's running for governor when he
goes to the parade he goes with his
third husband I saw him on Instagram I
was like 38 or something right and he's
good-looking like eat this dude he could
pick up boys the one thing is they're
all straight boys husband that one - no
but you know that they're all meth heads
so there's about the sad part yeah
you're right isn't that kind of
beautiful about meth heads is they don't
see orientation ever that is beautiful
no true love is matter that's why they
all judge and then the guy the skater
looking guy killed himself she did watch
it he didn't mean to follow him on
Instagram and say wait who Joey got it
that was probably the the craziest part
but then the funniest part cuz at the
funeral what when he was talking about
[ __ ] him in the butt or something it
all seems like a parody it just seems
like satire because it's like how is
this real life first of all the way that
guy killed himself he was [ __ ] around
like being like
he did that a lot like he would be like
bucho Krait now he'd do like [ __ ] like
edgy fat like comedy like edgy humor and
he did that all the time and he didn't
mean to kill himself he just didn't
think that there was a bullet inside his
doing a bit because he was like this gun
without the clip doesn't shoot guns like
no bullet inside well you know what when
I defend his right to make that bit
thank you
he went out with a bang he has a right
to do whatever bitty wants you remember
in the funeral where he made it all
about himself yes
he's saying a something he did a [ __ ]
performance and the mom was [ __ ] she
was [ __ ] Michael Scott exactly she is
trash Michael Scott so everybody before
was saying that Jo exotic is you how do
you feel now that you've seen it what
yeah I feel like I'm in between doc and
Jo exotic because you're not doc at all
sorry doc is the [ __ ] yoga man the
cult guy yeah that's like a harem of
ladies yeah just straight up Jo okay you
know why it's cuz Jo idolized doc and so
do i but I think I'm more blue leg like
Jo exotic yeah oh you think I don't
think you and the real Jo get along that
why are you similar yeah he's way too
sassy for you you'd be telling him I
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] what I can't
believe in this is sort of what I love
about it as well is how JAL exotic will
be like he's like advertising for his
place in a commercial and he's like you
gotta come down here and try my peaches
the best PC ever having whole [ __ ]
left and then he's like and he's like
and and then he walks outside with the
pizza he's a de tin from Tigers now what
I can't believe is that people will
watch that ad in these areas and they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yes I mean that's old
me right but I'm like I would never go
to this [ __ ] I also like how related you
would just walk I would in ironic and
ironic curve I think people are smart
enough to like be like well I'm not
gonna go for the pizza but those Tigers
look tight as [ __ ] and the guy in the
commercial is [ __ ] kooky I want to
meet that guy really oh you didn't eat
that I thought wow I just loved how he
beat the next tank babe
do you know what I'm saying when I went
when people who are if you're just
sitting there and you just got off of
your job and it's like six o'clock Joe
just said he watches the commercial and
he's like yeah that's tight I want to go
but do I love my job
no oh there's no Oklahoma
nothing happens there yeah my brother
lived in Oklahoma
nothing happens there true but but he
would watch this commercial and be like
this is ridiculous what does he do math
he was raised here though that's true
you're not really representing your
piece yet you're not I'm trying to get
in the headspace and it's your boy you
know what I think I'm the real redneck
you are wait I thought some people in
some parts of the world this could be
years old now but that they're like the
best thing to do in my town is to go to
Walmart or a Bass Pro also she studies
Joe exotic is stuck in the 80s like his
style his entertainment style everything
right so think about your parents going
on a road trip and then they're going
they see a billboard of the great thing
or whatever and then they pull over at
the gas station to see this thing which
is just like a shitty yarn ball or
whatever like the world's biggest potato
oh how do we have to go take pictures
it's a big potato
do you guys know who's see green Roy is
yeah dude Joe exotic saw them and was
like these people are [ __ ] sick
exactly like he basically just modeled
his whole life after that whole thing
the hair the white-trash sensibility
with all the leopard print and [ __ ] you
think he just did the Walmart version of
the biggest show my favorite part is
that chick gets her [ __ ] arm bit off
by a tiger and the next day she was back
to work she's like yes another day where
I'm talking love Tigers that's part of
what that is right when that happened he
went and first put on his EMS jacket and
then right behind all right it's like
super fancy imagine I get he's so like
flamboyant with everything like what I
can't do [ __ ] your medical work without
my proper uniform on the idea to that
your that your husband dies and you're
like you know what I needed to do look
at yourself in the mirror that morning
and this [ __ ] ridiculous to it like
you know I need to do I need to sing a
beautiful series of songs you know
that'll heal these people this music
pretty good it was it was hilarious but
the funny thing is he didn't sound like
that in real life so someone auto-tune
the [ __ ] out of that song I don't even
know if it was him it doesn't sound like
that all the time this the music video
was legendary
we're karabasan speeding my husband like
that he's as most of us and like half
the time he's advertising for his tiger
sanctuary or whatever his tiger farm and
then the other half of the time he's
just bashing on Carol Baskins like he's
just reading from her diary I know I
love we bought that he's like [ __ ]
like the pettiest [ __ ] just hours and
hours of live streaming of hating Karol
Bagh that's what Joe is doing now here's
his live stream yeah he's slowly turning
into him you ever hated somebody so
[ __ ] much that you were obsessed with
their destruction yeah right yeah I can
relate what the funniest part keep it to
myself
so do I was when they were talking about
Carol Basson's when they introduced
Carol Baskins and you know she's doing
her her web thing where she's like
hailey cool cats and kittens and then it
comes back to them and they're like yeah
she found the internet before all of us
she's got this big following she gets
like 800 years on her video and they're
like she gets so many views on her [ __ ]
but she crushing it oh she's crushing it
and then like she's usually like those
stupid dissolve wipes and [ __ ] and these
guys like man they're so jealous
they're like she went next level on this
[ __ ] we had we knew we had a ramp up our
show after we should've working genius
it's like when I watch tubers and
they're like oh man we're going next
[ __ ] level we got blu-ray cameras and
[ __ ] and I'm like you still make [ __ ]
videos just filming them with a high-res
camera but what was impressive though is
I think her Facebook following is in the
millions now we're back then back then
yeah it's crazy you know white tiger god
what's that the the Billy famous
Instagram account white tiger black
Jaguar I think yeah yeah he like [ __ ]
hates both of them he's like anyone that
owns animals are just [ __ ] trash
people he was like hell Baskins the cat
yeah the cat world is that is like
everyone wants to be the top cat
everyone's judging everyone else that's
him I follow him though I know when he
does it right yeah but this just made me
want to go to a cat sanctuary you're
like
see he was a commercial and he goes I
could eat pizza next to Tiger I'm sad I
don't know the the jokes on exuse still
there it's like Gotham and what you want
to free him so you could go to his I
want it yeah but then I'm probably gonna
go visit Doc's no you can't because he
probably kills all those baby cuz yeah
that's okay okay we let Joe's exotic out
of jail we have a reality TV film crew
follow him to the first thing I don't
agreement thank you
just give the world something to watch
right now because you know he [ __ ]
burned down all that footage we would
have had so much more tiger king like
the reality show like eped like mad
episodes he's so crazy cuz he films
everything that he even went to his
lawyer like I feel like that's his
lawyer was like burn that [ __ ] down and
he filmed that part and he still gave
that over to whoever to put in
documentary no the other documentary
crew they secretly filmed that
conversation with the lawyer you can't
do that legal burned his own kid in that
one-party state so okay so that's I'm
saying we put like a [ __ ] a part of
his probation is he has to wear like a
bracelet around his ankle and then we
get to [ __ ] watch all of it I think
that's a fair deal like he's in a
sanctuary he's in a tiger sanctuary
basically he's caged but wherever he
wants to go we camera crews following
like house arrest a police escort maybe
or theme park arrest or like zoo arrest
he's he can only stay in a zoo yeah and
that's it only with Tigers but then what
we have like hopefully you know you can
have boyfriends or whatever come over
can we have a crossing between like him
and Jersey Shore and like Jersey Shore
visits jobs odd but just the way Jersey
Shore is like that type of like party
and like the in house stuff and they
start the work like doing that but Joe
exotic edition yeah I'm into that I want
to see LSD parties yeah I heard his
party's crazy well I want to see how he
parties I want to see how he works I
want to see how what like type of a
roommate he'd be I would love to eat
pizza in front of a joke sock in a cage
oh yeah well you know we're all looking
at Jill exotic and taking pictures of
him and stuff and being like and I go up
to the cage and
while Tigers are hanging out with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]